Remember when the news was boring, and politics was boring? That happened, right? I'm not imagining that. You were there. I was there. That happened in our lives. I miss it. I didn't appreciate what a good thing it was when we had it.
还记得新闻和政治都很枯燥的时候吗？那种日子确实存在过，对吧？我没记错，你经历过，我也经历过。那是我们生活中的一部分。我怀念那时候。当初拥有它的时候，我并没有意识到那是多么美好的事。
I don't know about you, but me-- I've spent a full week obsessively reading about Judge Kavanaugh, and watching videos online, and calling people to discuss it. And I know this is just daily life in our totally divided country these days, but can I say, for me-- again, for me-- of all the moments we've had these last few years where red America and blue America look at the exact same event and come to radically different conclusions-- to me, this one feels the worst.
我不知道你们怎么样，反正我是……我整整花了一周时间，疯狂地阅读关于卡瓦诺法官的报道，观看在线视频，并不断找人讨论这件事。我知道，在我们这个彻底分裂的国家，这已是日常，但能不能让我说一句——再次声明，仅代表我个人——在过去几年里，我们目睹了红色的美国和蓝色的美国看着同一事件却得出截然不同的结论，而这一次，我觉得是最糟糕的。
I think because the original hearing itself with Dr. Ford and Judge Kavanaugh-- the testimony was just so long. It was so many hours. And then both witnesses were so emotionally raw that even watching it was emotional. It was upsetting. And then since that hearing, we've had this week of waiting for the FBI report, which held us all for a week in that same state of agitation and disbelief-- Republican disbelief at the Democrats, Democrats' disbelief at the Republicans. But even in moments like this one, there are people who haven't picked a side.
我想是因为福特博士和卡瓦诺法官的原始听证会实在是太长了。耗时太多小时。两位证人在情绪上都极度痛苦，以至于观看过程本身都让人情绪波动。这令人心烦意乱。听证会结束后，我们又经历了一周对FBI报告的等待，这一周我们都处于同样的焦虑和怀疑中——共和党人怀疑民主党人，民主党人怀疑共和党人。但即便在这样的时刻，仍有人没有选边站。
And incredibly, sometimes, those people are the ones who have to decide. They have to cast a vote in the United States Senate. And it does not seem fun for them.
令人难以置信的是，有时正是这些人不得不做出决定。他们必须在美国参议院投下一票。这对他们来说似乎一点也不好玩。
Today on our show, we have somebody in that situation in our first act-- Arizona Senator Jeff Flake. In our second act, we leave Washington behind. We have somebody who's literally deciding on a man's life or death, with no real experience or understanding of how to do it. Both those people, having to make these huge decisions-- they are not comfortable at all.
在今天的节目中，我们的第一幕就有一位处于这种处境的人——亚利桑那州参议员杰夫·弗莱克。在第二幕中，我们暂时离开华盛顿。我们将讲述一个人在毫无实际经验或理解的情况下，正决定着一个人的生死。这两个人都不得不做出如此重大的决定，他们感到非常不安。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One. Judge.
第一幕：法官。
So Senator Jeff Flake was one of the central players in the drama on Capitol Hill this last week. Turn on the TV and you'd see his tortured face. He dragged his decisions down to the wire over and over. He was undecided, then seemed like a no on Kavanaugh, then was a yes, then was a let's wait a week. It was Jeff Flake who made the Senate wait for a new FBI investigation. Then he was a yes again.
亚利桑那州参议员杰夫·弗莱克是上周国会山戏剧性事件的核心人物之一。打开电视，你就能看到他备受煎熬的脸。他一次又一次地将决策拖到最后一刻。他当时犹豫不决，看起来像是要投反对卡瓦诺的票，然后又像是赞成，接着又变成“让我们再等一周”。正是杰夫·弗莱克让参议院等待FBI的新调查。随后他又变成了赞成。
Our producer, Zoe Chace, has spent a lot of time with Jeff Flake over the last year. You may remember the hour-long episode she did, recording him for months as he tried to pass some kind of DACA bill. And she was with him in the days before and after the Kavanaugh hearing, watching what he was going through and talking to him about how he made his choices. Here's Zoe.
我们的制片人佐伊·蔡斯在过去一年里花了很多时间和杰夫·弗莱克相处。你们可能还记得她做的那期长达一小时的节目，记录了他数月来试图通过某种DACA法案的历程。她在卡瓦诺听证会前后陪伴着他，观察他所经历的一切，并和他讨论他如何做出选择。接下来请听佐伊的报道。
The first thing I want to talk about is the elevator. It's a big story-- how Jeff Flake changed his mind because two women accosted him on an elevator. I'm here to tell you that's not a true story. That's not what changed his mind.
我想谈的第一件事是电梯。这是一个大新闻——关于杰夫·弗莱克因为两名女性在电梯里拦截他而改变主意。我在这里告诉你们，那不是真的。那并不是改变他主意的原因。
Look at me when I'm talking to you! You're telling me that my assault doesn't matter!
我跟你说话的时候看着我！你是在说我的性侵遭遇无关紧要！
I was there, right behind the women yelling. That's why my recording isn't as clear as what you heard on CNN. I'm just staring at Flake, peering out from the elevator. He had just stood me up for an interview.
我就在那些大喊大叫的女性身后。这就是为什么我的录音不像你在CNN上听到的那样清晰。我只是盯着弗莱克，从电梯里往外看。他刚放了我的采访鸽子。
Jeff Flake's face can be a little deceiving. He looks kind of miserable a lot of the time when inside, he's just humming a little tune. In this case, though, I think he was miserable. He had just released a statement saying he was going to vote for Kavanaugh. He had dashed right past a bunch of CNN reporters, and around the corner to get to the elevator, to get to the vote. And now he was stuck.
杰夫·弗莱克的脸有时很有欺骗性。他看起来总是一副苦恼的样子，而内心可能正在哼着小曲。但在这种情况下，我认为他确实很苦恼。他刚发布了一份声明，称他将投票支持卡瓦诺。他快步从一群CNN记者身边经过，绕过拐角来到电梯，准备去投票。现在他被困住了。
You are allowing someone who is unwilling to take responsibility--
你允许一个不愿承担责任的人——
Ma'am, I'd be happy to take you--
女士，我很乐意带你——
--for his own actions--
——对自己行为的人——
Talk-- ma'am?
女士？
--to sit in the higher court of the country.
——进入这个国家的最高法院。
And then he went to the meeting, where he asked for an FBI investigation for one week.
然后他去了会议室，在那里他要求进行为期一周的FBI调查。
And what they said in that elevator door appears to have led a US senator to change his mind. Their words have now reverberated around this country.
而电梯门里的那些话似乎导致了一位美国参议员改变了主意。她们的话如今在这个国家引起了回响。
Flake had declared that he would be voting for Kavanaugh's nomination. Then he was confronted by a mob of screaming protesters, the youth wing of the Democratic Party. Jeff Flake crumbled.
弗莱克曾宣布他将投票支持卡瓦诺的提名。然后他被一群尖叫的抗议者拦截，那是民主党青年翼的人。杰夫·弗莱克崩溃了。
Archila was one of the two women in that confrontation with Senator Flake. Good morning.
阿奇拉是那次与弗莱克参议员对峙的两名女性之一。早上好。
Good morning.
早上好。
When that elevator door closed with Senator Flake, did you think that history might change?
当电梯门在弗莱克参议员面前关上时，你有想过历史可能会改变吗？
Archila and Maria Gallagher-- the other woman at the elevator-- they always hedge how influential they were. But lots of others don't. I'm reading things like, it was the elevator pitch that altered the trajectory of American history. An online site, "Support the heroes who convinced Flake," raised over $30,000 in a couple days.
阿奇拉和玛丽亚·加拉格尔——电梯里的另一位女性——总是对自己发挥的影响力轻描淡写。但其他人不这么看。我看到诸如“正是电梯里的那番话改变了美国历史的轨迹”之类的说法。一个在线网站“支持说服弗莱克的英雄”在几天内筹集了超过3万美元。
Lots of people love this version of events, and I think it's because they just want to believe protest works. So much of these last two weeks has been people watching the same stuff on TV, and seeing what they want to see. Here's how I know that story about the elevator, about how it changed Jeff Flake's mind, is not true. First of all, I saw him shake his head no when asked about it by other reporters.
很多人喜欢这个版本的叙事，我认为是因为人们只是想相信抗议是有效的。过去两周的很大一部分内容，就是人们看着电视上同样的东西，却看到了他们想看到的内容。这就是为什么我知道关于电梯如何改变杰夫·弗莱克主意的那个故事是不真实的。首先，我亲眼看到他向其他记者否认了这一点。
And did the women who confronted you this morning, did they have any role in changing your mind?
今天早上拦截你的那些女性，在你改变主意这件事上起到了什么作用吗？
Also, we talked about it.
我们谈论过这个。
That wasn't the thing. It was a thing.
那不是决定性因素。它算是一个因素。
It was a thing-- just not the thing that convinced him. Protesters don't affect him like that. I've seen him confronted by protesters over the health care bill, the tax vote, the Dreamers. And for days now, the Capitol building has been choked with them. They're stopping senators as they move through the halls-- sometimes chanting, sometimes telling horrific, very personal stories of sexual assault.
它是一个因素——但不是说服他的那个因素。抗议者并不能那样影响他。我见过他在医疗法案、税收投票、“梦想者”法案期间被抗议者拦截。连日来，国会大厦里挤满了他们。他们在走廊里拦截参议员——有时高喊口号，有时讲述可怕且非常私人的性侵故事。
It's everywhere, and it's a lot. Just the day before, Flake and I got in an elevator on the other side of the building. He was in the middle of a story about Lindsey Graham.
到处都是，确实很多。就在前一天，弗莱克和我乘电梯去了大楼的另一边。他当时正讲着一个关于林赛·格雷厄姆的故事。
Lindsey pulled me aside last night.
林赛昨晚把我拉到一边。
Women jumped on the elevator with us. They wore "be a hero" T-shirts, and "I believe women" T-shirts. They were filming him and calling out, "Do you believe women, Senator Flake?"
女性们和我们一起跳进了电梯。她们穿着“成为英雄”和“我相信女性”的T恤。她们在拍他，喊着：“弗莱克参议员，你相信女性吗？”
Do you believe them? Do you support women?
你相信她们吗？你支持女性吗？
We support women.
我们支持女性。
Do you believe women?
你相信女性吗？
We support women.
我们支持女性。
We believe women.
我们相信女性。
Do you believe women?
你相信女性吗？
Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。
We believe survivors.
我们相信幸存者。
Senator Flake? What do you have to say? Please? Do you have something you can say to women right now, and the survivors?
弗莱克参议员？你有什么想说的吗？求你了？你现在有什么话可以对女性和幸存者说吗？
Glad we're having this hearing today.
很高兴我们今天举行了这次听证会。
Yes.
是的。
Are you going to do the right thing?
你会做正确的事吗？
I'm glad we're having the hearing.
我很高兴我们举行了听证会。
Because it's not your body!
因为那不是你的身体！
Does it affect you when people yell at you like that?
当人们那样对你大喊大叫时，这会影响你吗？
The benefits of being shallow.
肤浅的好处。
That's Flake making fun of himself. We've talked about this before. Like lots of men his age, he doesn't connect too well to emotions.
那是弗莱克在自嘲。我们之前谈过这个。像许多他那个年纪的男人一样，他不太擅长处理情感连接。
John McCain would have done the right thing.
约翰·麦凯恩会做正确的事。
And he walked into the hearing to listen to Dr. Ford and Judge Kavanaugh, not sure what to do.
他走进听证会去听福特博士和卡瓦诺法官的证词，并不确定该怎么做。
Before I explain what happened next, I want to just say, going into a day like this undecided is both very rare for a senator, and very rare for everyone in America right now. I don't think being undecided could have been more scarce that day. Think about it. Do you know anybody who didn't already know who they would believe, and who they would not? The one time he spoke in the hearing, he sounded just as unsure as he had going in. And it was at the end of the day.
在我解释接下来发生什么之前，我想先说，带着未定的立场走进这样的一天，对参议员来说非常罕见，对当下的美国每个人来说也非常罕见。我不认为那天还有比“犹豫不决”更少见的状态了。想想看。你认识谁不是已经决定了自己相信谁、不相信谁吗？他在听证会上唯一一次发言时，听起来和他进来时一样不确定。那是在那天结束的时候。
This is not a good process, but it's all we've got. And I would just urge my colleagues to recognize that, in the end, we are 21 very imperfect senators trying to do our best to provide advice and consent. And in the end, there is likely to be as much doubt as certainty going out of this room today. And just have a little humility on that front. So thank you.
这不是一个好的程序，但这是我们所能拥有的全部。我只想敦促我的同事们认识到，最终，我们是21位很不完美的参议员，试图尽我们所能提供建议和同意。而最终，今天走出这个房间时，怀疑可能和确定一样多。在那一点上保持一点谦卑吧。谢谢。
If you watch the news, you know at least the outlines of what followed. But just to explain-- because I think you can't understand what happens at the end with Jeff Flake unless you know what happens here-- the night after the Ford-Kavanaugh testimony, Thursday night, Flake stays up all night, freaking out over what to do. Some close friends told him about their own sexual assaults. He talked to advisors. He talked to lawyers, going over what was said.
如果你看新闻，你应该知道随后发生的事情的大致轮廓。但我还是要解释一下——因为我认为如果你不知道这里发生的事情，你就无法理解杰夫·弗莱克最后做了什么——在福特和卡瓦诺作证后的那个周四晚上，弗莱克彻夜未眠，对该怎么做感到惊恐万分。一些亲密的朋友向他讲述了他们自己的性侵经历。他咨询了顾问。他咨询了律师，仔细核对了证词。
He found Ford credible and convincing, but he came back, over and over, to the fact that there was nothing corroborating her testimony. No one else could put him in the room that night. He found Kavanaugh credible also, and his anger wasn't as off-putting to him as I thought it might be. His staff said they'd never seen him like this.
他觉得福特的可信度和说服力很强，但他又一次次回到一个事实：没有任何证据能佐证她的证词。那天晚上没有其他人能证明他在房间里。他也觉得卡瓦诺是可信的，卡瓦诺的愤怒并没有像我预想的那样让他感到厌恶。他的员工说从未见过他这样。
It was agonizing, I have to say. It really was-- more so than anything, any decision, on a vote. I've had debates with staff, and discussions late last night, too. And it was pretty raw, you know?
必须说，这令人痛苦。确实是——比任何投票决定都更令人痛苦。我和员工进行过辩论，昨晚深夜也进行了讨论。这非常真实，你知道吗？
The next morning, of course, Flake finally releases the statement. He's going to vote yes on the judge.
第二天早上，当然，弗莱克终于发表了声明。他将投票支持这位法官。
Whatever you do, they say, in the end, you've got to come back to presumption of innocence.
他们说，无论你做什么，归根结底，你都必须回归到无罪推定。
He goes to the elevator, gets yelled at on TV, then to the committee meeting. You know that part.
他走向电梯，在电视上被叫骂，然后前往委员会会议。那部分你们都知道。
Meanwhile, Chris Coons, Democratic senator from Delaware, is on his way to the meeting with a bunch of reporters. And he gets the news that Flake's a yes. He chokes up, reportedly, says, "Oh, fuck," and then, "We each make choices for our own reason. I'm struggling. Sorry." A lot of tears in the Capitol those two days.
与此同时，来自特拉华州的民主党参议员克里斯·孔斯正带着一群记者去开会。他得到了弗莱克赞成的消息。据报道，他哽咽着说：“哦，该死，”然后说，“我们每个人都因为自己的原因做出选择。我很挣扎。抱歉。”那两天国会大厦里泪水很多。
The meeting begins. The two sides rail against each other. Flake's stressing, gets up and makes a call. He probably checks Twitter, because he usually does. But he says he did not see how viral the elevator video was going, and the bad PR of it. He says he wasn't thinking about that at all.
会议开始了。双方互相指责。弗莱克压力很大，起身打了个电话。他可能查看了推特，因为他通常会这样做。但他表示，他并不知道电梯视频的传播速度有多快，以及带来的负面公关影响。他说他根本没考虑这些。
So he comes back. And then Coons gives a speech at the committee meeting that he said was directed at one man-- Jeff Flake. They're actually friends. They're on the Foreign Relations Committee together. They've been all over Africa together, too. And they have breakfast almost every week at the prayer breakfast. Coons is Presbyterian, Flake reminds me, while he's a Mormon. And there was something very Presbyterian, he said-- just unadorned and practical-- about the way Coons was speaking.
所以他回来了。然后孔斯在委员会会议上发表了一场演讲，他说这是针对一个人的——杰夫·弗莱克。他们实际上是朋友。他们一起在外交关系委员会工作。他们也一起去过非洲各地。他们几乎每周都在祈祷早餐会上共进早餐。弗莱克提醒我，孔斯是长老会教徒，而他是摩门教徒。他说，孔斯的说话方式非常有长老会风格——简单直接且务实。
And I will say, briefly, at the outset, that before yesterday began, I prayed. I prayed for Dr. Ford and her family. I prayed for Judge Kavanaugh. And I prayed for all who would watch yesterday, uncertain whether we could conduct ourselves respectfully.
我想简要说一句，在昨天开始之前，我祈祷了。我为福特博士和她的家人祈祷。我为卡瓦诺法官祈祷。我为所有昨天会观看的人祈祷，不确定我们能否表现得互相尊重。
I know since the day that my Democratic colleagues and I learned of these allegations, we've had one consistent request-- to allow the FBI to investigate them in a nonpartisan, professional, even-handed manner, and deliver their findings to us so that we could reach a conclusion.
我知道自从我和我的民主党同事获悉这些指控的那天起，我们就有一个一致的请求——允许FBI以无党派、专业、公平的方式调查这些指控，并将调查结果提交给我们，以便我们得出结论。
Flake and I talked about that moment on the phone.
弗莱克和我在电话里谈到了那一刻。
That it had an impact, and the biggest impact, I'm sure. That is far more accurate than this narrative out there that it was the protesters that moved it.
这产生了影响，而且肯定是最重大的影响。这比外面流传的所谓抗议者促成这一结果的说法准确得多。
That day at the meeting, Flake gets up, walks across the room, taps Coons on the shoulder, and they're on their way to a deal. Later, he explained what was going through his head.
那天在会议上，弗莱克起身，走到房间对面，拍了拍孔斯的肩膀，他们准备达成交易。后来，他解释了他脑子里在想什么。
I wasn't at peace with where I was. And when I got over there and then saw the food fight-- just resumption of yesterday's-- I said, we can't-- I can't do this. I know how this is being viewed out there, that people see this rush to judgment, and as Republicans move through and not look at the facts, and just try to get this done as quickly as possible-- and that's not good. It's not good. Long term, look what it does to the institution, it's just horrible.
我对我当时的位置并不心安。当我走过去看到那场口水战——只是昨天的重演——我说，我们不能——我不能这样做。我知道外面的人是怎么看这件事的，人们看到了这种匆忙的判断，共和党人继续推进而不去查看事实，只是试图尽快完成这件事——这不好。这不好。长期来看，看看它对制度造成了什么影响，这太可怕了。
Preserving the integrity of the process on the Senate Judiciary Committee is a much less romantic story than the one about two survivors of sexual assault changing a senator's mind at the last second. That's what happened, though.
维护参议院司法委员会程序的完整性，比那个关于两名性侵幸存者在最后一秒改变了参议员主意的浪漫故事要乏味得多。但事实就是这样。
And finally, that day, the world sees Jeff Flake find a third way. It's something he's been looking for for a long time on a lot of issues-- a way to vote with his Republican colleagues, but stand for certain principles with the Democrats. It's the weirdest niche. But he's a weirdo right now-- a ghost Republican. He doesn't really have a constituency he's speaking for, being anti-Trump but pro his policies.
最终，那天世界看到了杰夫·弗莱克找到了第三条路。这是他在很多议题上寻找了很久的东西——一种既能与共和党同事一起投票，又能与民主党站在一起坚持某些原则的方法。这是一个最奇怪的定位。但他现在就是一个异类——一个幽灵共和党人。他并不真正代表任何选民群体，他反特朗普但支持他的政策。
He's retiring from the Senate in a few months. As he says, he could never have done something like this if he were still running for office. There's no value to reaching across the aisle, he says. There's no currency for that anymore. If you do that, you'll lose. So there is not much crossing over to the other side ever, by anybody-- which is maybe why, when you do cross over, this is what happens.
几个月后他就要从参议院退休了。正如他所说，如果他还在竞选公职，他永远不可能做出这样的事。他说，跨越党派界限已经没有价值了。那已经没有市场了。如果你那样做，你就会输。所以几乎没有人会跨越到另一边——这也许就是为什么当你真的跨过去时，就会发生这样的事。
How you doing, Senator?
你好吗，参议员？
Doing well. How are you?
很好。你好吗？
Good for you, man.
真不错，伙计。
Thanks.
谢谢。
God bless you.
上帝保佑你。
Appreciate it.
很感激。
This is the consequence-- New York City loves Senator Jeff Flake. I know, because the day after the committee vote, I picked him up at Penn Station and got him a taxi.
这就是后果——纽约市喜欢杰夫·弗莱克参议员。我知道，因为在委员会投票后的第二天，我在宾夕法尼亚车站接了他，并帮他打了一辆出租车。
But I also called a car.
但我还叫了一辆专车。
Oh, you did?
哦，你叫了？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, well don't.
哦，别。
Because I was like, the Senator? I don't know if he wants to wait in a taxi line. I don't know if that's a thing you're used to doing.
因为我在想，参议员？我不知道他是否想在出租车站排队。我不知道这是否是你习惯做的事。
Yeah, I'll be all right.
没关系，我会没事的。
No Capitol police protection, no staff-- just me, and a lot of new Jeff Flake fans.
没有国会警察保护，没有助手——只有我和一群杰夫·弗莱克的新粉丝。
Could we take a picture with you?
我们可以和你合影吗？
Sure. You bet.
当然。没问题。
I end up taking pictures for them.
我最后成了给他们拍照的人。
Do you think they know that you're going to vote for Kavanaugh?
你觉得他们知道你要投票支持卡瓦诺吗？
I don't know. I think that will all go away if I do.
我不知道。我想如果我投了，这一切都会消失。
86th and Central Park West.
第86街和中央公园西。
OK.
好的。
I don't know. I think people are so starved for any sign of bipartisanship.
我不知道。我想人们太渴望看到任何党派合作的迹象了。
I'm going to go ahead and say bipartisan, in New York, means you agree with the Democrats.
我就直说吧，在纽约，跨党派意味着你同意民主党的观点。
This is all happening because on my way back to New York from Washington on Saturday, I ran into Chris Coons on Amtrak. He told me Flake was on the Acela right behind us. That Flake had invited himself, along with Coons, to the Global Citizen Concert at The Great Lawn in Central Park, broadcast live on MSNBC. I can't think of a bluer place, to be honest-- a more on-the-nose location for the hashtag resistance.
这一切发生是因为周六我从华盛顿回纽约的路上，在美铁列车上遇到了克里斯·孔斯。他告诉我弗莱克就在我们后面的阿塞拉号列车上。弗莱克邀请了自己和孔斯参加在中央公园大草坪举行的全球公民音乐会，MSNBC对此进行了现场直播。老实说，我想不出比这更偏蓝的地方了——一个更符合“阻力”标签的地点。
So I'm surprised to hear Flake's coming too, and I text him to see if I can go. He gets me credentials, and I take him uptown. I get a little lost. Because I'm from here, I think I know where everything is, but I don't. And then we're running across the 86th Street transverse.
所以我很惊讶听说弗莱克也要来，我发短信问能不能去。他帮我弄到了证件，我带他去上城。我有点迷路了。因为我是本地人，我以为我知道所有地方，但其实不知道。然后我们跑过了第86街横贯通道。
Senator Flake? Good work.
弗莱克参议员？干得好。
Thank you.
谢谢。
New York loves you, Senator Flake.
纽约爱你，弗莱克参议员。
And we head to a little trailer backstage to meet up with Chris Coons. Outside, tens of thousands of people are already out on the lawn. These two senators are going to deliver a short, impromptu speech about bipartisanship to this crowd.
我们前往后台的一个小拖车里和克里斯·孔斯会合。外面，数万人已经在大草坪上了。这两位参议员要向这群人发表简短的、即兴的关于跨党派的演讲。
Can I ask you who's performing before them, and who's performing after?
能不能问一下谁在他们之前表演，谁在之后表演？
Cardi B.
卡迪·B。
Cardi B?
卡迪·B？
Is after.
是在后面。
Is after?
是在后面吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You guys are the opening act for Cardi B. I don't know if he knows who Cardi B is.
你们是卡迪·B的开场表演者。我不知道他知不知道卡迪·B是谁。
This is where Flake's reaching across the aisle gesture gets epically surreal-- and it's hard to top how surreal the week has been already. All these famous people keep popping into the trailer.
这就是弗莱克的跨党派姿态变得极度超现实的地方——这一周已经足够超现实了，很难再超越。所有这些名人都不断出现在拖车里。
What you did-- you're a hero. And it's so funny that other people don't know how simple it is to be a hero.
你所做的——你是英雄。而且很有趣，其他人不知道成为英雄是多么简单。
It's Robert Di Niro, who steps to Flake with a finger in his face, like a scene from Goodfellas.
那是罗伯特·德尼罗，他走到弗莱克面前，手指着他的脸，就像《好家伙》里的场景。
We rely on you. Too much had gone down with this guy. He's got to go. I know it's because they want the midterms, and this, and that. But we're beyond all that. We're beyond all that.
我们依靠你。这个人出了太多事。他必须走。我知道这是因为他们想要中期选举，还有这个那个。但我们已经超越了这些。我们已经超越了这些。
It's weird to hear Robert Di Niro say the word midterms.
听到罗伯特·德尼罗说“中期选举”这个词很奇怪。
I'm telling you, you're a hero, man.
我告诉你，你是英雄，伙计。
John Legend.
约翰·传奇。
I appreciate what you all did this week. And we just know that we're all watching and hoping that you make the right decision for the country. OK? That's all I'm saying. [LAUGHTER] You know how I feel about it.
我很感激你们这周所做的一切。我们只是知道大家都在看着，希望你们能为国家做出正确的决定。好吗？我只想说这些。[笑声]你知道我对此的感受。
The director Ava DuVernay.
导演艾娃·杜威内。
So thank you so much for listening to women.
非常感谢你倾听女性的声音。
Katie Holmes and Suri. Coons does not know who that is.
凯蒂·赫尔姆斯和苏瑞。孔斯不知道那是谁。
That's great.
太棒了。
I don't know how to answer that question.
我不知道怎么回答这个问题。
Bring her on in.
带她进来。
She's the actress who was--
她是那位女演员，曾经是——
Used to be married to Tom Cruise.
过去嫁给汤姆·克鲁斯。
--married to Tom Cruise.
——嫁给汤姆·克鲁斯。
That's great. I've heard of him. I am so useless.
太棒了。我听说过他。我真是太没用了。
Come in, Katie.
进来，凯蒂。
Hi, you.
嗨。
Good to see you.
见到你真好。
Thank you.
谢谢。
To be fair, neither of the senators seems to know who any of these people are-- except Di Niro. Everyone wants a picture with the senators.
平心而论，这两位参议员似乎都不知道这些人是谁——除了德尼罗。每个人都想和参议员合影。
Soon Coons and Flake are rushed towards the stage, continuing to be mobbed by the Hollywood resistance. Darren Aronofsky yells to them, "I'm a film maker. I made Black Swan."
很快，孔斯和弗莱克被簇拥着走向舞台，继续被好莱坞的“阻力派”围住。达伦·阿罗诺夫斯基对他们喊道：“我是电影制作人。我拍了《黑天鹅》。”
I'm a filmmaker. I made Black Swan. Thank you for everything you're doing right now.
我是电影制作人。我拍了《黑天鹅》。感谢你们现在所做的一切。
I go around to the front, to see how thousands of non-famous New Yorkers are receiving this still-Republican senator.
我走到前面，看看数千名非著名的纽约人是如何看待这位依然是共和党的参议员的。
Thanks to all of you global citizens--
感谢所有全球公民——
Fuck you!
滚你的！
--who have contacted us--
——联系我们的——
That's a real New York "fuck you." The call for bipartisanship is drowned out by calls for Cardi B.
那是地道的纽约式“滚你的”。对跨党派的呼吁被卡迪·B的欢呼声淹没了。
We're standing here, united for democracy.
我们站在这里，为了民主而团结。
Cardi! Cardi!
卡迪！卡迪！
As soon as they're offstage, though, the star treatment starts again. The Reverend Al Sharpton catches him, like we're on a red carpet.
不过，他们一离开舞台，明星待遇又开始了。阿尔·夏普顿牧师抓住了他，就像我们在走红毯一样。
Hey, Al.
嘿，阿尔。
Senator Coons just called you a hero.
孔斯参议员刚称你为英雄。
Naw. Naw, he's the guy. He's the guy. He's the guy.
不。不，他才是那个人。他是那个人。他是那个人。
"Do you think we can bring this country together?" Al says. It's like a left-wing farce at this point. Random bit players keep popping out to cast liberal spells. Chris Martin, from Coldplay, gives Flake a magic pin of some sort to keep in his pocket.
“你觉得我们能让这个国家团结起来吗？”阿尔说。此刻这简直是一场左翼闹剧。各种随机的小角色不断冒出来施展自由派咒语。酷玩乐队的克里斯·马丁给了弗莱克某种魔法别针，让他放在口袋里。
Oh, yeah. Jeff, here. Take this. Put it in your pocket in times of trouble. All right?
哦，是的。杰夫，给你。拿着这个。在困难的时候把它放在口袋里。好吗？
Thank you. Oh!
谢谢。哦！
Flake drops it. Chris Martin leaves. We have a moment to sit down.
弗莱克掉了别针。克里斯·马丁离开了。我们有时间坐下来。
What is it like?
感觉怎么样？
It's intimidating.
这让人望而生畏。
Was it?
是吗？
Yeah. Well I mean, it's not something you know. This is different than a conference on Social Security reform or-- you know?
是的。我是说，这不像社会保障改革会议，或者——你知道吗？
It's not the Cato Institute.
这不是卡托研究所。
Different. No, it's not. [LAUGHTER] Far from.
不同。不，不是。[笑声] 远非如此。
What's it like having people like Robert Di Niro and John Legend be like, you're a hero? For a week-long FBI investigation?
像罗伯特·德尼罗和约翰·传奇这样的人说你是英雄，是什么感觉？就为了一个为期一周的FBI调查？
Well, it'll last a week, too. My next vote, for Kavanaugh or for something they don't like, and I'm a pariah again.
嗯，这也只会持续一周。我的下一次投票，无论是为了卡瓦诺还是其他他们不喜欢的事，我又会变成贱民。
[LAUGHTER] So you enjoy it for a week.
[笑声] 所以你可以享受这一周。
Do you think they know you're still a Republican?
你觉得他们知道你还是共和党人吗？
You know, I think probably so. You enjoy it while you can.
你知道，我想大概知道。享受你能享受的时光吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Jeff Flake's had a rough few years. They hate him on the right, and he keeps disappointing the left. It feels good, for once, to be popular.
杰夫·弗莱克这几年过得很艰难。右翼讨厌他，左翼也总是失望。有一次能受欢迎，感觉不错。
Are you happy? Do you like it?
你快乐吗？你喜欢吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh, yeah. Every politician does. We like it. Politicians-- we feed on it. That's a-- whether we admit it or not.
哦，是的。每个政客都喜欢。我们喜欢它。政客们——我们以此为食。不管我们承不承认。
And then it happens, just like he predicted. After seven days of being treated as a Democrat-- or at least a Republican defector-- Flake comes home to the GOP. On Thursday, the FBI releases the report that he called for. On Friday, Flake announced his decision. He's a yes on Kavanaugh. I reached Chris Coons that afternoon.
然后它发生了，就像他预料的那样。在被当作民主党人——或者至少是共和党叛徒——对待了七天后，弗莱克回到了共和党阵营。周四，FBI发布了他要求的报告。周五，弗莱克宣布了他的决定。他投票支持卡瓦诺。那天下午我联系了克里斯·孔斯。
Look, Jeff and I both went to the same place, and read the same report. And I appreciate his friendship. We are viewing this through a different lens. Jeff is a conservative senator. He has always wanted a conservative on the Supreme Court. I am not, and I don't.
看，杰夫和我去了同一个地方，读了同一份报告。我很珍惜他的友谊。我们通过不同的视角看待这件事。杰夫是一位保守派参议员。他一直希望最高法院有一位保守派。我不是，我也不希望。
Coons thought the FBI report was a disgrace, basically. They didn't follow up on any leads, he said. It was not the investigation he had asked for last week. He was mad. Frustrated. Kept going off the record and raging. He would not tell me about his conversations with Jeff Flake after they both read the FBI report.
孔斯基本上认为FBI报告是一个耻辱。他说，他们没有跟进任何线索。这根本不是他上周要求的调查。他很生气。很沮丧。不断地脱稿抱怨。当两人读完FBI报告后，他拒绝告诉我他和杰夫·弗莱克的谈话内容。
I'm really trying not to either put words in his mouth or criticize him, because-- I am restraining myself from saying something that is not appropriate here.
我真的在努力不替他说什么话，也不批评他，因为——我正在克制自己不去说一些在这里不合适的话。
As soon as Flake voted Friday, he fled the Capitol. I talked to him in the car. People are mad at you again, I said. Well, that's how it goes, he said. Why did you vote yes, I asked him? Presumption of innocence, he told me, over and over. He was satisfied with the FBI report.
弗莱克周五一投票，就逃离了国会大厦。我在车里和他谈了谈。我说，人们又生你的气了。他说，事情就是这样。我问他为什么投票支持？他一遍又一遍地告诉我，无罪推定。他对FBI的报告感到满意。
Do you feel better now? You're kind of back among your people. You had kind of a week with the Democrats celebrating you, but you're back among your people.
你现在感觉好点了吗？你算是回到了你的同僚中。你和民主党人一起庆祝了一周，但你回到了你的人群中。
Do I have people? I guess so. I am a man, temporarily, without a party.
我有我的人群吗？我想是吧。我是一个暂时没有党派的人。
There is no bipartisan right now. There is no aisle to stand in the middle of. To quote a film that Robert Di Niro was not in, but kind of-- "Don't ever take sides with anyone against the family. Ever."
现在没有所谓的跨党派。没有可以站在中间的过道。用罗伯特·德尼罗没有出演过，但某种程度上体现的那句电影台词来说——“永远不要和任何人站在对立面反对这个家庭。永远不要。”
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program. Let's turn now to this recording that we found of Justice Anthony Kennedy. Kennedy, of course, is the retiring judge whose seat Brett Kavanaugh was nominated for, the swing vote on the Supreme Court for years. This is him being questioned in a Q&A back in 2010.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制片人之一。现在让我们转到我们找到的安东尼·肯尼迪大法官的录音。肯尼迪当然就是那位退休的法官，布雷特·卡瓦诺被提名为其继任者，多年来一直是最高法院的摇摆票。这是他2010年参加问答环节时的录音。
As you stand here today, Justice, a potential colleague is starting the confirmation process. How has the process changed since you went through it?
大法官，今天当你站在这里时，一位潜在的同事正在开始确认程序。自你经历该过程以来，这个过程发生了怎样的变化？
Well, I liked my own.
嗯，我喜欢我自己的那个。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Remember, the Senate is a political body, and they have to act in a political way. The framers knew that. And it's really not for me to tell the Senate how to structure that process. I do think it has the obligation to recognize the necessity of preserving the neutrality, and the independence, and the integrity of our court.
记住，参议院是一个政治机构，他们必须以政治方式行事。国父们知道这一点。而我真的不应该告诉参议院如何构建这个过程。我确实认为它有义务认识到维护我们法院的中立性、独立性和完整性的必要性。
What you should ask is whether the judge has the temperament, the commitment, the character, the learning. I think the judge should be broadly read. I, myself, was fascinated with political theory. If you ask what makes a good judge, you're going to get an autobiography, so you have to be careful about that.
你应该问的是，这位法官是否有气质、承诺、品格和学识。我认为法官应该博览群书。我自己就对政治理论很着迷。如果你问什么造就了一位好法官，你会得到一份自传，所以你必须小心这一点。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So the Senate has a-- really, very difficult position.
所以参议院处于一个——真的，非常困难的位置。
Kennedy was speaking to an audience including high school students. People asked him about his favorite cases, if he had always wanted to be on the Supreme Court-- no, by the way. He was funny. He was a good talker. And he explained his job-- how it works.
肯尼迪当时正在向包括高中生在内的观众讲话。人们问他最喜欢的案件，他是否一直想进入最高法院——顺便说一句，并没有。他很风趣。他是个很好的谈话者。他解释了他的工作——它是如何运作的。
We will meet, just the nine of us, and discuss the case. We begin in order of seniority, from the most senior judge to the least senior. And if the case is one in which there are great issues of public policy involved, we know that we're required to make a decision. The courts have been divided on it. And let's assume that it's a five-four case, and it's not just reverse or affirm. It's a question of the rationale, the principal, the reasons that you give.
我们会开会，就我们九个人，讨论案件。我们按资历顺序，从资历最深的法官到最浅的。如果该案件涉及重大的公共政策问题，我们知道我们必须做出决定。法院对此有分歧。让我们假设这是一个五比四的案件，不仅仅是推翻或维持。这是一个关于基本原理、原则、你给出的理由的问题。
And let's say it's five to four. The five in the majority don't have a lot of back slaps, and high fives, and thumbs up. There's a moment of awe as we realize, one of us will have to write an opinion that commands the allegiance of the American people. An opinion that explains, that teaches the principles of law, the principles of the Constitution, that control the result.
假设是五比四。多数派的五个人不会有太多的击掌、欢呼和点赞。那一刻有一种敬畏，因为我们意识到，我们中的一个人将不得不写一份能够获得美国人民效忠的意见书。一份解释、教授法律原则、宪法原则的意见书，这些原则控制着结果。
And when we issue that opinion in, say, an unpopular case, we draw down on a capital of trust. We make a withdrawal on the trust that the public has in our constitution. And it is our job always to replenish that trust by adhering to our judicial oath, by adhering to the principles of neutrality, and independence, and fairness, and quiet discussion, and decency, and courtesy, and scholarship. That's the way our court works.
当我们发布那份意见书时，例如在一个不受欢迎的案件中，我们消耗了一份信任资本。我们动用了公众对我们宪法的信任。我们的工作永远是修复这种信任，通过恪守我们的司法誓言，恪守中立、独立、公平、安静讨论、体面、礼貌和学术的原则。这就是我们法院的工作方式。
OK, one more story. I don't know if this tells us anything profound about Anthony Kennedy or the Supreme Court, but it's just fun to hear how he talks about this.
好的，再讲一个故事。我不知道这是否告诉了我们关于安东尼·肯尼迪或最高法院什么深刻的道理，但听到他这样谈论这件事很有趣。
I was meeting, one time, with our judges and attorneys in Alabama. And I think it was a Saturday morning. And for my schedule or theirs or both, it was at 9 o'clock in the morning. And they were dressed casually, ready to play golf or tennis. And they were gracious enough to hear me for a few minutes.
有一次，我和我们在阿拉巴马州的法官和律师会面。我想那是星期六早上。因为我的日程安排或者他们的，或者是两者的，是在早上9点。他们穿得很随便，准备去打高尔夫球或网球。他们非常客气地听我讲了几分钟。
And so I said, well, do you have any questions? And one attorney raised his hand and said, now, you have all that tremendous amount of reading to do-- all of those briefs. How do you possibly do that? I said, well, I have four clerks, and I divide them up among the clerks. Of course, I have to read them all.
所以我说，好的，你们有什么问题吗？一位律师举手说，现在，你有那么多繁重的阅读任务要做——所有那些案情摘要。你是怎么做到的？我说，嗯，我有四个书记员，我把它们分给书记员。当然，我必须把它们全部读一遍。
And if they're very difficult cases, I will take them home and read the briefs a second time over the weekend, just before argument. And I like music. I have opera playing in the background. And I sometimes have cases that are one-opera cases, sometimes two-opera cases.
如果是非常困难的案件，我会把它们带回家，在周末，也就是辩论前，再读一遍摘要。我喜欢音乐。我的背景里放着歌剧。我有时会有“一部歌剧”的案子，有时是“两部歌剧”的案子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, the minute I said that, I kind of knew I lost the audience. They were too polite to roll their eyes, but it sounded kind of, what, intellectually pretentious? You know, here's some eastern guy talking about the opera. So I thought I'd lost the audience, but I was saved because an attorney in the room raised his hand. He said, well, I have a rule like that when I write those briefs. I said oh, yes? He said, I have a one six-pack brief and a two six-pack brief.
嗯，我一说出口，我就知道我失去了听众。他们太礼貌了，没翻白眼，但听起来有点，什么，理智上的自负？你知道，这里有个东部来的家伙在谈论歌剧。所以我以为我失去了听众，但我得救了，因为房间里的一位律师举起了手。他说，嗯，我在写那些摘要时也有类似的规则。我说，哦，是吗？他说，我有一份“一六罐装”的摘要和一份“二六罐装”的摘要。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I said, I think I remember your last one. It was a three six-pack brief.
我说，我想我记得你的上一份。那是一份“三六罐装”的摘要。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Who'da thunk? Lawyer likes beer.
谁能想到呢？律师喜欢啤酒。
Thanks to the Forum Club of the Palm Beaches for that recording of Anthony Kennedy. Coming up, a total and complete amateur has to decide a death sentence. His only previous experience in these matters? Watching Law & Order. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
感谢棕榈滩论坛俱乐部提供那份安东尼·肯尼迪的录音。接下来，一个完全彻底的业余选手必须做出死刑判决。他之前在这类事情上的唯一经验？观看《法律与秩序》。稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台为您播出，节目继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Unhappy Deciders"-- stories of people who are saddled with difficult, momentous decisions to make-- decisions that will determine someone's fate for the rest of their life, decisions that weigh on them.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“不情愿的决定者”——讲述那些背负着艰难、重大决定的人们——这些决定将决定某人余生的命运，这些决定沉重地压在他们心头。
Act one of our program today was about a judge. Act Two is about a jury. And we'll just get right to it.
我们节目的第一幕是关于一名法官。第二幕是关于一个陪审团。我们直接切入主题。
This story comes to us from the podcast Heavyweight. If you haven't heard Heavyweight, it's hosted by one of our regular contributors here, and a former producer of This American Life, Jonathan Goldstein. And the premise of the show is that each episode, people come to Jonathan with something in their life that they want to fix, they want to deal with, they want to make right with another person. Usually it's something they've been living with for a long time, and they're uncomfortable with.
这个故事来自播客《重量级》。如果你没听过《重量级》，它是我们这里常驻撰稿人之一、也是《美国生活》前制片人乔纳森·戈德斯坦主持的。这个节目的前提是，每一集都有人带着他们生活中想要修复、处理、想要与他人和解的事情来找乔纳森。通常是他们忍受了很长时间且感到不舒服的事情。
And Jonathan plays a kind of bumbling Detective Columbo figure, but one who actually is kind of bumbling and awkward. But he gets the people to sit down, and talk, and hash things out. Many of the episodes are really funny. The one that we have today is a more serious one. Anyway, here's Jonathan Goldstein.
乔纳森扮演一个笨拙的科伦坡式侦探角色，但确实有点笨拙和尴尬。但他会让人坐下来谈话并解决问题。很多集都非常有趣。我们今天播出的这一集是比较严肃的一集。不管怎样，这是乔纳森·戈德斯坦。
In 2008, Sven received a letter for jury duty.
2008年，斯文收到了一封陪审团传票。
Lots of people would say, oh, this is such a boring thing. Oh no, I hope I don't get jury duty. But I was more curious and interested in the process. And I liked watching stuff like Law & Order, and other things like that.
很多人会说，哦，这真是太无聊了。噢不，我希望我别被选中。但我对这个过程更好奇且感兴趣。我喜欢看《法律与秩序》之类的节目。
SVU, Criminal Intent-- Sven liked them all. He was a software developer, newly married. And he and his wife had just bought a new house-- his first. The house had a flagpole in the front and a hammock out back. After work he'd come home, relax on the couch, and watch his legal dramas. Jury duty was going to offer an inside view of the TV shows he loved.
《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》, 《犯罪倾向》——斯文都喜欢。他是一名软件开发人员，刚结婚。他和妻子刚买了一栋新房子——这是他的第一套房。房子前面有一根旗杆，后面有一个吊床。下班后他回到家，在沙发上放松，看他的法律剧。陪审团职责将提供他所钟爱的电视节目的内部视角。
I wasn't fooled into thinking it was some weird, glamorous thing like that. But I thought juries were interesting-- the idea of judging your peers right or wrong. I've always sort of had a sense of civic responsibility.
我没有被误导认为这是一种奇怪的、光鲜亮丽的事情。但我认为陪审团很有意思——评判你同僚是非的理念。我一直有一种公民责任感。
In my book, the only thing that makes responsibility less appealing is adding the word civic to it. Paying your taxes, appearing before a zoning board-- not for me. Like most, when I appeared for jury duty, I prayed for dismissal.
在我看来，让责任变得没那么吸引力的唯一方法就是在前面加上“公民”两个字。纳税、在分区委员会前出庭——那不适合我。像大多数人一样，当我去执行陪审义务时，我祈祷被拒绝。
Not Sven, though. During the selection process, he engaged with the questions the lawyers posed as best he could. And when he was asked how he felt about capital punishment, he answered candidly.
但斯文没有。在筛选过程中，他尽其所能回应律师提出的问题。当被问及对死刑的看法时，他坦诚地回答了。
I believe bad people should be punished in that way, or could be punished in that way. And so I wouldn't say I was strongly for it, but I wasn't against it. And consequently, I got on the jury.
我相信坏人应该以那种方式受到惩罚，或者可以以那种方式受到惩罚。所以我不会说我强烈支持它，但我也不反对。因此，我进入了陪审团。
The case was The State of Texas versus Paul David Storey. Storey was a 22-year-old accused of the murder of Jonas Cherry, the manager of a mini golf course in Hurst, Texas. Storey and an accomplice forced Cherry into the back office, made him unlock the safe, and put the money-- a few hundred dollars-- in a bag. And then they shot him multiple times.
这个案件是得克萨斯州诉保罗·大卫·斯托里案。斯托里是一名22岁的年轻人，被控谋杀赫斯特市迷你高尔夫球场的经理乔纳斯·切里。斯托里和同伙强迫切里进入后台办公室，让他解锁保险箱，把钱——几百美元——放进一个袋子里。然后他们开了好几枪杀了他。
Storey's trial lasted two weeks, and would have felt familiar to anyone who watches TV courtroom dramas. There were lawyers with thick binders full of ballistics reports and medical examinations, character witnesses were called, and disturbing photographs of the victim's body were shown. The only thing missing was any suspense about the verdict.
斯托里的审判持续了两周，对任何看电视法庭剧的人来说都会感到熟悉。有带着装满弹道报告和医疗检查厚活页夹的律师，传唤了品格证人，并展示了受害者尸体的令人不安的照片。唯一缺少的是关于判决的悬念。
There was no doubt that he was guilty of murder and robbery. And so really, as a jury, all we had to worry about was sentencing.
毫无疑问，他犯有谋杀和抢劫罪。所以实际上，作为陪审团，我们只需要担心量刑。
The jury had to decide between life imprisonment or the death penalty. It seemed the victim's family knew what they wanted. "It should go without saying," the prosecutor announced to Sven and the other jurors, "that all of Jonas's family and everyone who loved him believe the death penalty is appropriate."
陪审团必须在终身监禁或死刑之间做出决定。看来受害者的家人知道他们想要什么。“不言而喻，”检察官向斯文和其他陪审员宣布，“乔纳斯的所有家人和爱他的人都认为死刑是恰当的。”
The prosecutor asked the jurors to sentence Paul Storey to death. The instructions stated that for the death penalty to be imposed, the jurors must judge three things to be true-- that Paul Storey was guilty, that there were no mitigating circumstances-- like, say, mental illness or provocation-- and lastly, that Storey posed a future threat to his community.
检察官要求陪审员判处保罗·斯托里死刑。指示说明要实施死刑，陪审员必须判断三件事为真——保罗·斯托里有罪，没有减轻情节——比如，精神疾病或挑衅——最后，斯托里对他的社区构成了未来威胁。
That was the one I had issue with. I seriously doubted that he would be a continuing threat to the prison community.
这是我存疑的那一项。我严重怀疑他会对监狱社区构成持续威胁。
And what was it about Paul Storey that made you feel like you just didn't necessarily see him as a continued threat?
保罗·斯托里的什么让你觉得你不一定把他视为持续威胁？
A couple of things. His testimony--
几件事。他的证词——
The young man Sven saw in the courtroom appeared confused, in over his head, and remorseful. This was his first offense. And some of the evidence suggested that it was Storey's accomplice who had been the mastermind behind the horrible crime, as well as the one who had fired first. Sven was certain that Paul Storey should be punished, but he didn't think he should be put to death.
斯文在法庭上看到的年轻人显得困惑、力不从心且悔恨。这是他的初犯。一些证据表明，斯托里的同伙才是这起可怕犯罪背后的主谋，也是第一个开枪的人。斯文确信保罗·斯托里应该受到惩罚，但他不认为他应该被判死刑。
But in the jury chambers, there was a very different feel. Everyone else was in favor of the death penalty. And so faced with almost a dozen other people who already felt strongly, I didn't think I could convince anyone of what I was thinking. I'll be honest-- I was scared.
但在陪审团房间里，气氛非常不同。其他人也都赞成死刑。所以面对另外十几个已经有强烈意见的人，我不认为我能说服任何人。说实话——我很害怕。
At 27, Sven was the youngest juror by several years. And he was the kind of guy who avoided speaking up at all costs. At home, if his neighbor parked in his space, he let it go. At the office, if his boss told him to do something, even if he disagreed, he did it without question. In other words, even though he'd been looking forward to being a juror, when he found himself in the jury room, Sven wasn't exactly Henry Fonda in 12 Angry Men.
27岁时，斯文是陪审员中最年轻的，比别人小好几岁。他是一个不惜一切代价避免发表意见的人。在家里，如果邻居停在他的车位上，他就算了。在办公室，如果老板让他做什么，即使他不同意，他也会毫不质疑地去做。换句话说，尽管他期待成为陪审员，但当他发现自己身处陪审团室时，斯文并不完全是《十二怒汉》里的亨利·方达。
The way he understood it, the jurors had to reach a unanimous decision. And the idea of swaying 11 strangers over to his way of thinking seemed impossible. He was also afraid that if he opposed the group, it would result in a hung jury and a mistrial. They'd have to start the whole process over again with a new jury. Everyone would be mad at him. So Sven said nothing.
按照他的理解，陪审员必须达成一致决定。而说服11个陌生人认同他的想法似乎是不可能的。他还担心，如果他反对群体意见，会导致陪审团僵持和流审。他们必须和一个新的陪审团重新开始整个过程。每个人都会对他生气。所以斯文什么也没说。
An hour and a half later, Paul Storey was sentenced to death by lethal injection.
一个半小时后，保罗·斯托里被判注射死刑。
It was hard to look at him during the sentencing. We sat waiting for the judge to ask us, what's the sentencing? And everyone was really tense. And the woman next to me-- another juror-- began crying. She was trying to hide it. And I gave her my handkerchief. And she just wept.
在量刑时很难看着他。我们坐着等法官问我们，判决是什么？每个人都很紧张。我旁边的女人——另一位陪审员——开始哭泣。她试图隐藏它。我给了她我的手帕。她只是哭泣。
Then the foreman announced the verdict, and I think his mother cried out. They had an exit for us to go through after we collected our things. And we were out of that courtroom fast.
然后法官宣布了判决，我想他的母亲大声哭了出来。他们有一个出口让我们在收集东西后离开。我们很快就离开了那个法庭。
It felt like a mistake right away.
这立刻感觉像是一个错误。
Sven went over to his parents' house, where he had dinner and drank scotch with his dad. He told his family about the trial. And then he went home, where he had more to drink before bed.
斯文去了他父母家，在那里他吃晚饭并和父亲喝了苏格兰威士忌。他向家人讲述了审判过程。然后他回家，在睡觉前喝了更多的酒。
And then that was that. Then it was over. And then I went on with my life.
然后就是那样了。然后结束了。然后我继续我的生活。
Or at least he tried to.
或者至少他试图这么做。
But what did you do with these feelings? I was just stuck. It was done. It was cast in stone. And-- yeah, no, I felt terrible. I felt massive amounts of regret. I felt guilty, sending someone to death row.
但你如何处理这些感受？我只是被卡住了。它完成了。它被刻在了石头上。而且——是的，不，我感觉糟透了。我感到巨大的悔恨。我感到内疚，把某人送上了死囚牢房。
When you think about the people that a trial effects, you think of the victims and their loved ones. And you think of the accused, their families, and what they're going through. You don't usually think about what it does to the jurors. But for Sven, the trial wasn't something you could put behind him at the crack of a gavel.
当你想到审判影响的人时，你会想到受害者和他们的亲人。你会想到被指控的人，他们的家庭，以及他们正在经历的事情。你通常不会想到这会对陪审员产生什么影响。但对斯文来说，审判不是法槌一敲就能抛之脑后的事。
In the days and weeks after the verdict, he read every article about the case he could find. But the more he read, the more shame he felt. So eventually he just stopped.
判决后的几天和几周里，他读了每一篇关于这个案子的文章。但读得越多，他感到的羞耻就越多。所以最终他停止了。
I realized it wasn't really healthy.
我意识到这不健康。
At the time, Sven was a regular drinker.
当时，斯文是个经常喝酒的人。
And it only got worse after the trial. It got a lot worse after the trial.
审判后变得更糟。审判后变得糟糕得多。
He was drinking more, beginning as soon as he got home from work, and spending more days hungover. His wife didn't understand what was going on.
他喝得更多，下班一回家就开始喝，宿醉的日子也越来越多。他的妻子不明白发生了什么。
It may have contributed to my divorce, which was the following year.
这可能促成了我的离婚，那是在第二年。
A year after the trial, and Sven's life had changed. The new house with the hammock and the flagpole was sold, and Sven moved out of Texas.
审判一年后，斯文的生活变了。那个有吊床和旗杆的新房子卖掉了，斯文搬出了得克萨斯州。
Sven settled in Olympia, Washington, to start his life over. He found an apartment for himself and his cat, Niku. But he couldn't shake his memories of the trial. When a friend bought a secondhand silver Nissan, Sven couldn't stop thinking about how that was the same car the victim, Jonas Cherry, had driven. When addressing coworkers, the name Jonas would accidentally slip from Sven's lips. And Paul Storey, who still was on death row, was never far from Sven's mind.
斯文在华盛顿州奥林匹亚定居，重新开始生活。他为自己和他的猫尼库找了个公寓。但他无法摆脱对审判的记忆。当一个朋友买了一辆二手银色尼桑时，斯文忍不住想到那和受害者乔纳斯·切里开的车一模一样。在和同事交谈时，乔纳斯这个名字会不小心从斯文的嘴里滑出来。而仍在死囚牢房里的保罗·斯托里也从未离开过斯文的脑海。
He tried to escape through alcohol, but it didn't free him from his shame. Sometimes, after a night out drinking, he'd return to a Facebook page Paul Storey's mother had made for her son. One mother had already lost her son. And now, because Sven had been too afraid to speak up, another mother was going to, as well.
他试图通过酒精逃避，但这并不能让他摆脱羞耻。有时，在喝完酒的一晚后，他会回到保罗·斯托里的母亲为儿子建立的Facebook页面。一位母亲已经失去了儿子。现在，因为斯文太害怕不敢说出来，另一位母亲也要失去儿子了。
I'm not trying to excuse his crime. It was terrible. But to send a guy to death? The presence in your mind, the recurring thoughts about it-- can that go away?
我不是在试图为他的罪行开脱。那很可怕。但把一个人送去死刑？你脑海中的存在，关于它的反复思考——那能消失吗？
For all the bad rap it gets, shame offers a certain safety. It provides a comfortable hole to hide in, away from the judgment of others. But it can also lead to isolation and inertia. And for eight years-- eight years in which Paul Storey sat on death row, awaiting an execution date-- Sven barely talked about the trial with anybody.
尽管名声不好，羞耻确实提供了一定的安全性。它提供了一个舒适的洞穴供人躲藏，远离他人的评判。但它也可能导致孤立和惰性。而八年来——保罗·斯托里在死囚牢房等待执行日期的八年里——斯文几乎没跟任何人谈论过审判。
But then, in 2016, the year after Paul Storey's federal appeal had been denied, a reporter writing a series of articles about the judicial system approached Sven about his experience as a juror. Sven was tired of being all alone with his regrets. And so, for the first time, he opened up about his feelings.
但在2016年，在保罗·斯托里的联邦上诉被驳回后的那一年，一位为司法系统系列文章撰稿的记者联系了斯文，询问他的陪审员经历。斯文厌倦了独自面对悔恨。因此，这是他第一次敞开心扉谈论自己的感受。
"I felt guilty," he told the reporter, "and sad, and a little helpless. I don't think I made the right call." Sven had hoped that talking about the trial might help. And it did-- up until the article was published. That was when Sven received an uncomfortable phone call from a lawyer who had read the article.
“我感到内疚，”他告诉记者，“而且难过，还有点无助。我不认为我做了正确的决定。”斯文曾希望谈论审判可能会有所帮助。确实有用——直到那篇文章发表。那时斯文接到了一个读过文章的律师打来的不舒服的电话。
Sven was at work. Fearing his coworkers might overhear, he took the call outside, behind his office building. It was there that he learned that, eight years earlier, he had misunderstood a key part of the jury instructions.
斯文当时在工作。担心同事听到，他走到办公楼外接听了电话。就在那里，他了解到八年前他误解了陪审团指示的一个关键部分。
I thought incorrectly, essentially. I believed I would have to convince everyone to choose life imprisonment when, in fact, all I had to do was decline the death penalty. And that's all it would have taken.
我的想法本质上是不正确的。我以为我必须说服所有人选择终身监禁，事实上，我所要做的只是拒绝死刑。这就可以了。
Preventing the death sentence only required one dissenting vote-- a vote Sven could have cast. So there would have been no mistrial, no hung jury. And instead of the death penalty, Paul Storey would have gotten life in prison without parole.
阻止死刑只需要一张反对票——斯文本来可以投那一票的。所以不会有流审，不会有僵局。除了死刑，保罗·斯托里本会得到不得假释的终身监禁。
That would have been nice to know. I could have changed-- well, I could have let him live.
如果知道这一点就好了。我本来可以改变——好吧，我本来可以让他活着。
After the article was published, something else happened-- something Sven never expected or wanted. Paul Storey's mother, Marilyn, got in touch.
文章发表后，又发生了一件事——斯文从未预料到或想要的。保罗·斯托里的母亲玛丽莲联系了他。
She reached out with an email filled with sentiments of forgiveness. She had forgiven me. And if I wanted to, I could reach out and talk with her. And knowing that there is that forgiveness-- it felt so weird, like it wasn't something I could completely understand.
她发来一封充满宽恕之情的电子邮件。她原谅了我。如果我愿意，我可以联系她和她谈谈。知道那种宽恕存在——感觉很奇怪，好像我无法完全理解。
For Sven, it didn't make sense. Why would Marilyn want to speak with him? How could she, of all people, forgive him for something he couldn't forgive himself for?
对斯文来说，这没有意义。玛丽莲为什么要和他谈话？她怎么可能，在这所有人中，原谅一个他自己都无法原谅的人？
I didn't know how to deal with-- I still kind of don't know how to deal with that. And I couldn't match her message.
我不知道如何处理——我现在还是不知道如何处理。我无法回应她的信息。
How do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Well, I wasn't sure how to reply with something as powerful as that. It just floored me. I didn't know what to say.
嗯，我不确定该如何用像她那样有力的文字回复。这彻底震撼了我。我不知道该说什么。
Sven was never able to write Marilyn back.
斯文一直没能给玛丽莲写回信。
I did-- began a reply, but I didn't have the courage to finish or send it. It's just, there's so much pain in there, and-- I feel like I really wrecked things up.
我确实——开始写回复，但我没有勇气完成或发送。只是，里面有太多的痛苦，而且——我觉得我真的把事情搞砸了。
A few months after Sven received Marilyn's email, an execution date was set. The state would put Paul Storey to death on April 12 of 2017. But then something unexpected happened. Glenn and Judith Cherry, the parents of the victim, came forward.
在斯文收到玛丽莲邮件后的几个月，执行日期定下来了。州政府将于2017年4月12日对保罗·斯托里执行死刑。但意想不到的事情发生了。受害者的父母格伦和朱迪思·切里站了出来。
It seems that, at the trial, the prosecution had lied. The Cherrys, in spite of their son's murder, are and always have been against capital punishment. In a video they released publicly, Judith Cherry presents a statement which reads in part, "We do not want Paul Storey's family, especially his mother, to witness the purposeful execution of their son. They are innocent of his deeds."
看来在审判中，检方撒了谎。切里夫妇尽管遭受丧子之痛，一直都反对死刑。在他们公开发布的一段视频中，朱迪思·切里发表了一份声明，部分内容写道：“我们不希望保罗·斯托里的家人，尤其是他的母亲，目睹他们儿子的故意处决。他们对他的行为是无辜的。”
Based on this testimony, with only five days to spare, Paul Storey's execution was postponed. When news of the stay of execution reached Sven, it felt like a second chance, an opening to finally respond to Marilyn's email. But he didn't.
基于这份证词，在仅剩五天的情况下，保罗·斯托里的死刑被推迟了。当死刑暂缓的消息传到斯文耳中时，这感觉像第二次机会，一个终于回复玛丽莲邮件的突破口。但他没有。
It's now been over two years. He's remarried, doesn't drink anymore-- but he still hasn't contacted Marilyn.
现在已经过去两年多了。他再婚了，不再喝酒了——但他仍然没有联系玛丽莲。
And so at this point, what do you want?
那么此刻，你想要什么？
I need to apologize for not doing what I should have done to begin with, for not following my gut, for not trying.
我需要为没有做我本来应该做的事道歉，为没有追随直觉，为没有尝试而道歉。
Shame leads to inertia. And as even the most casual reader of the fundamentals of physics will tell you, an inert object will remain inert until it is acted upon by an external force. In other words, it takes a little nudge. And who better to supply a little nudge than a little "nudge?"
羞耻导致惰性。正如任何一个物理学基础知识的读者都会告诉你，惰性物体在受到外力作用前会保持惰性。换句话说，需要一点推动力。而有什么比一点“ nudge（推动）”更好的助力呢？
And so I write Marilyn a letter. "I know this is a really sensitive and deeply personal issue," it reads, "and I hope I'm not being too forward." I ask Marilyn if she remembers a juror by the name of Sven Berger. About a week later, I receive a note back via email-- "Thank you so much for your letter," Marilyn writes. "I have no ill will toward Mr. Berger. I have offered him my email address, as well as my phone number, with no reply."
所以我给玛丽莲写了封信。“我知道这是一个非常敏感且极其个人化的问题，”信中写道，“希望我没有太唐突。”我问玛丽莲是否还记得一个叫斯文·伯格的陪审员。大约一周后，我收到了一封邮件回复——“非常感谢你的信，”玛丽莲写道。“我对伯格先生没有恶意。我向他提供了我的电子邮件地址和电话号码，但他没有任何回复。”
She also forwards her original email to Sven-- the one she sent two years ago, the one he can't stop thinking about. When I read it, I'm expecting a grand gesture of forgiveness. But Marilyn never mentions forgiveness-- never even uses the word. Instead, it's just six short sentences in which Marilyn thanks Sven for the article, and says she shared it with her son. Her tone is breezy. She ends with, "have a great day," exclamation mark.
她还转发了她给斯文的原始邮件——她两年前发送的那封，他无法停止思考的那一封。当我读它时，我期待着一种伟大的宽恕姿态。但玛丽莲从未提到宽恕——甚至没用过这个词。相反，那只是六个简短的句子，玛丽莲感谢斯文的文章，并说她和儿子分享了它。她的语气很轻松。结尾是，“祝你愉快”，带感叹号。
I understand that Sven, consumed by guilt, would read so much into so little. But what I don't understand is why Marilyn sent him the email in the first place.
我理解斯文被内疚吞噬，会对这么少的内容进行过度解读。但我无法理解的是，为什么玛丽莲当初会给他发那封邮件。
I know you had jokingly mentioned breakfast.
我知道你开玩笑地提到早餐。
Oh, I was joking.
哦，我在开玩笑。
I have a couple little things, if you get peckish at all-- some croissant, some of this stuff. I don't know, some cookies.
如果你饿的话，我有一些小东西——一些牛角面包，一些这个。不知道，一些饼干。
No, I'm fine.
不，我很好。
Yeah? OK.
是吗？好的。
Marilyn lives in Fort Worth, Texas. The two of us meet in a hotel suite downtown where I can't stop offering her food that she can't stop refusing.
玛丽莲住在得克萨斯州沃思堡。我们俩在市中心的一家酒店套房见面，我不断地拿食物给她，而她不断地拒绝。
Do you want to have a coffee, or a tea?
你想喝咖啡还是茶吗？
No.
不。
Marilyn is tall and stately, with smiling eyes. She's in slacks, boots, and a cropped blazer, all in black. She sits on the end of the couch, next to an empty armchair, and tries to give me a sense of what her life was like before the trial.
玛丽莲高挑庄重，眼神带笑。她穿着休闲裤、靴子和短款西装外套，全黑打扮。她坐在沙发尽头，旁边是一张空扶手椅，试着让我了解审判前她的生活是什么样。
I was always the life of the party. I mean, I was a jokester-- oh, make sure you have Marilyn there, because she's going to keep the party going. I was always kind of the one that everybody went to. People knew you can call me in the middle of the night. If you need somebody to come pick you up, call Marilyn. She'll get up. She'll go do it.
我以前总是派对上的灵魂人物。我是个爱开玩笑的人——哦，一定要让玛丽莲去，因为她会把派对搞得有声有色。我总是那个每个人都会来找的人。人们知道可以在半夜给我打电话。如果你需要有人来接你，打给玛丽莲。她会起床。她会去做。
Since the trial, Marilyn doesn't feel like the same person. Every day, she's reckoning with the horror of her son's crime, and worrying endlessly about his safety in prison. Her friends have fallen away. The thing that's hardest, though, is how the people who remain-- the people closest to her-- now look upon her son.
审判以来，玛丽莲觉得自己不像同一个人了。每一天，她都在承受儿子犯罪的恐怖，并为他在监狱里的安全无尽担忧。她的朋友们都疏远了。最困难的是，留下的人——那些最亲近的人——现在是怎么看她儿子的。
She says that everyone's passed judgment on Paul, written him off as worthless and un-redeemable. And they blame him for her pain.
她说每个人都对保罗做出了判断，把他写成毫无价值、不可救药的人。他们把她的痛苦归咎于他。
And I even had a family member where-- Paul is the cause of all of this. And that was very hurtful. It's like they wanted everything to be OK, but that's my child. And I love him. And I'm not going to ever stop fighting for him.
我甚至有个家庭成员说——保罗是这一切的原因。那非常伤人。就好像他们希望一切都好起来，但那是我的孩子。我爱他。我永远不会停止为他而战。
Fighting for him meant working with her son's lawyers to change his sentence to life in prison.
为他而战意味着与她儿子的律师合作，将他的刑期改为终身监禁。
Paul's appeals were exhausting.
保罗的上诉令人精疲力竭。
It took up all of her time and energy, which affected the hospitality job she worked out for over 30 years.
这占用了她所有的时间和精力，这影响了她从事了30多年的酒店服务工作。
It became extremely hard for me to concentrate at work. And I feel like it cost me my job.
我很难在工作中集中注意力。我觉得这让我失去了工作。
After losing her job, Marilyn then lost her house. She was forced to move in with her younger son.
失去工作后，玛丽莲又失去了房子。她被迫搬去和年轻的儿子住。
So it's like, at my age, where I thought that I'd be getting ready to retire, I'm starting over. So that's a hard thing.
所以，在我这个年纪，我以为我该准备退休了，结果却要从头开始。这很难。
10 years after the trial, and everyone-- her friends, her family-- have all moved on. So when Marilyn read Sven's article, she saw in him someone like her-- someone who had never gotten past that final day of the trial.
审判10年后，每个人——她的朋友、家人——都已向前看。所以当玛丽莲读到斯文的文章时，她在斯文身上看到了像她一样的人——一个从未走出审判最后一天的人。
When they actually gave the sentence-- the death penalty-- I thought I had died. I thought I had literally died. It didn't even register. Because I'm just like, what just happened? What have they done? My whole time there, I was just looking at the jurors to try to read, OK, what are they thinking? What are they doing? I wanted them to know, if I could only tell them what kind of person he is.
当他们真的做出判决——死刑——时，我以为我死了。我以为我真的死了。这甚至没有进入我的大脑。因为我只是想，发生了什么？他们做了什么？我在那儿的整个时间，我只是盯着陪审员，试图读取，好吧，他们在想什么？他们在做什么？我希望他们知道，如果我能告诉他们他是什么样的人。
And I want people to know-- they assume that if you're involved in a heinous crime like that, that you're a monster. But he wasn't a monster.
我希望人们知道——他们认为如果你卷入那样的恶性犯罪，那你就是个怪物。但他不是怪物。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
I think that might be him. So he's going to come up.
我想那可能是他。他要上来了。
Marilyn and I have been talking for about an hour and a half when the front desk phones.
玛丽莲和我谈了大约一个半小时，前台打来电话。
I think it probably--
我想这大概是——
Now, how do you pronounce his name?
那么，他的名字怎么发音？
Sven.
斯文。
Is it "Sven?"
是“斯文”吗？
Sven-- S-V-E-N.
斯文——S-V-E-N。
Sven, yeah. Sven.
斯文，是的。斯文。
Sven, yeah.
斯文，是的。
Sven. I hope I get that before he gets here.
斯文。希望在他来之前我能学会。
But before we get a chance to practice our Svens, Sven is at the door.
但在我们有机会练习“斯文”之前，斯文已经站在门口了。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi, Sven. I'm Jonathan. It's very nice to meet you.
嗨，斯文。我是乔纳森。见到你很高兴。
It's nice to meet you in person.
见到你很高兴。
Marilyn is here.
玛丽莲在这里。
Hi.
嗨。
Now, how do you pronounce your name?
那么，你的名字怎么发音？
Sven.
斯文。
Sven lingers in the door of the hotel room.
斯文在酒店房间门口徘徊。
Here, sit down. Have a seat over there.
来，坐下。坐到那儿去。
He's bespectacled, and neatly dressed in a collared shirt and sweater. He looks around and clears his throat.
他戴着眼镜，穿着整洁的带领衬衫和毛衣。他环顾四周，清了清嗓子。
I'm a little nervous. So there was--
我有点紧张。所以有——
The last time Marilyn and Sven had been in the same room was 10 years ago, at the trial. Marilyn was seated behind the bar. Sven sat in the jury box. But today, he sits down in the empty armchair beside her. He can't quite bring himself to look at her. As he tells Marilyn what it was like to receive her email, he gazes down at his lap.
玛丽莲和斯文上一次共处一室是在10年前的审判中。玛丽莲坐在栏杆后面。斯文坐在陪审团席位上。但今天，他坐在她旁边的空扶手椅上。他无法注视她。当他告诉玛丽莲收到她邮件的感觉时，他盯着自己的膝盖。
It was very surprising. And I read it, and I reread it. And I even began several letters that never went anywhere. I didn't know what to say. What do you say about that? I don't want to write a letter that's trying to make me feel better. Do you know what I mean?
非常令人惊讶。我读了它，又读了一遍。我甚至开始写几封信，但都无疾而终。我不知道该说什么。关于那个你能说什么？我不想写一封试图让自己感觉更好的信。你知道我的意思吗？
Mmm hmm.
嗯哼。
From the moment the vote was cast, I had regret. I thought, I am doing the wrong thing. And although it was great hearing that you forgave me, I couldn't forgive myself, exactly. And I can't even imagine how you must feel.
从投票的那一刻起，我就感到后悔。我想，我做错了。尽管听到你原谅我感觉很好，但我无法原谅自己。我甚至无法想象你的感受。
First of all, I want to say I don't want you to feel shame, because my son was involved in a crime. He made a wrong choice. And I don't ever want you to feel that you did anything wrong. You did what you felt you had to do at the time. But you came back. And for you to come out, and for you to say hey, I made a mistake-- you right your wrong.
首先，我想说我不希望你感到羞耻，因为我的儿子卷入了一场犯罪。他做出了错误的选择。我永远不希望你觉得你做了任何错事。你做了你当时觉得必须做的事。但你回来了。你站出来，你说嘿，我犯了一个错误——你改正了你的错误。
I can tell by Sven's face that he isn't convinced. He doesn't feel like he's righted anything. This is because for years, Sven has been avoiding all traces of the case-- no googling, no newspapers. He never even read the article he'd been interviewed for. So he doesn't know what Marilyn knows, which is the chain of events that his article set in motion.
我从斯文的脸上看得出，他并不信服。他觉得自己没改正任何事。这是因为多年来，斯文一直避免接触案件的任何痕迹——不谷歌搜索，不看报纸。他甚至从未读过他被采访的那篇文章。所以他不知道玛丽莲所知道的事，也就是他的文章引发的一系列事件。
The jury instructions for Paul Storey's case were written in dense legalize, and nowhere in their nine pages did they state that a single dissenting vote can prevent the death penalty. In fact, courts in Texas are prohibited from telling jurors that. In theory, that's to encourage them to arrive at a consensus. But what it means is Sven's confusion wasn't his fault.
保罗·斯托里案件的陪审团指示写在密集的法律术语中，在九页纸的任何地方都没有说明一张单一的反对票可以阻止死刑。事实上，得克萨斯州的法院禁止告诉陪审员这一点。理论上，这是为了鼓励他们达成共识。但这意味着斯文的困惑不是他的错。
For years, legal advocates had wanted to bring a bill before the legislature that would clarify the instructions. But they needed someone who could say, I would have done things differently if I had understood. Marilyn explains to Sven that with him, and the things he'd said in the article, they had finally found that person.
多年来，法律倡导者一直想向立法机构提出一项法案，以澄清这些指示。但他们需要一个能说“如果我早明白了，我会采取不同做法”的人。玛丽莲向斯文解释，有了他，以及他在文章中所说的话，他们终于找到了那个人。
There are senators in the state of Texas who have introduced a bill based on you to change the way the instructions are given to a death penalty jury.
得克萨斯州有参议员根据你的情况提出了一项法案，旨在改变向死刑陪审团提供指示的方式。
Sven, slumped in his chair, straightens up.
斯文瘫在椅子上，坐直了。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. You have no idea what sort of impact you had.
是的。你根本不知道你产生了什么样的影响。
I don't know anything about that.
我对此一无所知。
You were very instrumental.
你起到了非常重要的作用。
This is-- I'm shocked.
这——我很震惊。
While his eyes have tended to dart around the room, looking at me or down at his hands, right now Sven is looking directly at Marilyn. She tells him that had he in fact voted against the death penalty at her son's trial, these attempts at reform might never have happened.
当他的目光倾向于在房间里游移，看向我或看向他的手时，此刻斯文正直视着玛丽莲。她告诉他，如果他在她儿子审判时真的投了反对死刑的票，这些改革尝试可能永远不会发生。
I'm a firm believer that things happen for a reason, because this is not just about my son. It's about other mothers' sons that are on death row, as well. So if this can help any other case outside of Paul's, then we've served our purpose. You came forward. So I look at you as my hero.
我坚信事情的发生是有原因的，因为这不仅仅是关于我的儿子。这也关于其他死囚牢房里母亲们的儿子。所以如果这能帮助保罗之外的任何案件，那么我们就达到了目的。你站了出来。所以我把你视为我的英雄。
Sven physically shrinks from the word hero. It's as though she's placed a large, awkward crown atop his head.
斯文因“英雄”这个词身体往后缩了缩。就好像她在他的头上放了一顶巨大、笨重的王冠。
Wow. That's not the way I'd considered myself, or my actions in any way. I don't feel that special.
哇。我从未这样看待过自己或我的行为。我不觉得我那么特别。
Oh, to me.
哦，对我来说是的。
But I appreciate all your words.
但我感谢你的所有话语。
To me, you are.
对我来说，你是。
That's a lot to process. I had no idea.
这需要消化。我根本不知道。
You didn't know any of this?
你一点都不知道吗？
No.
不知道。
Oh, the articles-- there is a really good one in The Texas Tribune. I actually printed it out for you, but I wasted Coca-Cola on it, so I didn't want to give you an article that was-- but you should look it up.
哦，那些文章——得克萨斯论坛报上有一篇非常好的。我本来打印出来给你，但我把可乐溅在上面了，所以我不想给你一份——但你应该去查查。
This blows my mind. Sorry, I'm a little at a loss for words. Walking in here, I didn't know what to expect. And I was a little nervous. I do feel, even just now, a little bit of weight taken off my shoulders.
这太让我震撼了。抱歉，我有点语塞。走进这里时，我不知道会发生什么。我有点紧张。但我确实感到，即使就在现在，我的肩膀上卸下了一点负担。
I can tell.
我看得出来。
This helps. This helps so much. Oh, this helps so much.
这有帮助。这帮助太大了。哦，这帮助太大了。
After all these years, Sven is finally able to accept Marilyn's forgiveness, even if he still isn't ready to forgive himself.
这么多年后，斯文终于能接受玛丽莲的宽恕，尽管他仍然没准备好原谅自己。
It chews me up, today, that I didn't express a dissenting opinion. I should have spoken up, at least. I mean, I didn't think he would be a danger to the prison community. I didn't see a hardened criminal there. I got the impression of sort of a kid who was in a situation he didn't know how to handle. I saw someone who made a terrible mistake, and someone I did not believe would do it again.
直到今天，我没有表达反对意见依然折磨着我。我至少应该说出来的。我是说，我不认为他会对监狱社区构成危险。我没在那儿看到一个十恶不赦的罪犯。我得到的印象是一个陷入他不知道如何处理的困境的孩子。我看到的是一个犯了可怕错误的人，我不相信他会再犯。
As Sven speaks, Marilyn's eyes well up.
当斯文说话时，玛丽莲的眼睛湿润了。
I kept looking at the jurors, and I was like, it has to be somebody on there that feels, and that can see through all of this that the prosecutor is presenting, and everything, to know that my son is not a monster.
我一直在看那些陪审员，我想，肯定有人能感受到，有人能透过检察官呈现的一切，来看清我的儿子不是一个怪物。
No. No, never. I never saw Paul as a monster.
不。不，永远不是。我从未把保罗视为怪物。
After the crime, Marilyn's family never saw her son the same way again. From that moment on, he was nothing more than a murderer. And on the final day of the trial, 12 jurors confirmed that judgment. Her hope had been that maybe someone had seen something else. It wasn't a hope for someone to recognize in her son anything special or good. She just wanted them to see him as something other than a monster.
犯罪后，玛丽莲的家人再也没用同样的眼光看她儿子。从那一刻起，他不过是个杀人犯。而在审判的最后一天，12名陪审员确认了这一判断。她的希望是也许有人看到了别的东西。这并不是希望有人认出她儿子有什么特别或好的地方。她只是想让他们把他看作不是怪物。
I didn't see that.
我没看到。
Thank you. I appreciate that so much.
谢谢。我非常感激。
Throughout the trial, I never saw that once.
整个审判过程中，我一次都没看到。
Paul Storey is still on death row, and Sven still can't reverse the sentence. But in speaking aloud the words that Marilyn's been repeating to herself for so long, Sven's made her feel less alone.
保罗·斯托里仍在死囚牢房，斯文仍然无法推翻判决。但通过大声说出玛丽莲这么久以来一直在对自己重复的话，斯文让她感到不再那么孤单。
You have-- some of the hurt that I have carried on my heart for the last 12 years. You just lifted it. You have no earthly idea what that meant to me. It meant a lot. And for you to say that-- it really eased my heart.
你——我过去12年来心头上背负的一些伤痛。你刚刚把它卸下了。你根本不知道那对我意味着什么。那意义重大。你能说出那些话——它真的安慰了我的心。
After years of worry over what to say to Marilyn, Sven's finally found the right words.
经过多年关于该对玛丽莲说什么的担忧，斯文终于找到了正确的话语。
I'm sorry I never wrote back.
我很抱歉我从未回信。
That's OK. I totally understood. That's a lot.
没关系。我完全理解。那太沉重了。
Since Sven and Marilyn's meeting, a judge made an official recommendation that, based on Glenn and Judith Cherry's testimony, his sentence be changed to life in prison without parole. Though the Court of Criminal Appeals still has to make a final ruling, Storey's lawyers are hopeful-- and so is Marilyn.
在斯文和玛丽莲会面后，法官根据格伦和朱迪思·切里的证词正式建议将他的刑期改为不得假释的终身监禁。尽管刑事上诉法院仍需做出最终裁决，但斯托里的律师们充满希望——玛丽莲也一样。
As for Sven, after finally responding to Marilyn, he decided to send a letter of apology to Paul Storey. "I couldn't find the strength to speak up in the jury room," he wrote, "and that is a mistake I will carry forever." Sven has yet to hear anything back.
至于斯文，在终于回复玛丽莲后，他决定给保罗·斯托里写一封道歉信。“我没能在陪审团室里找到勇气说出来，”他写道，“那是我将永远背负的错误。”斯文尚未收到任何回音。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of Heavyweight. His producer for this story was Stevie Lane. Heavyweight just started their third season with an episode about comedian Rob Corddry. You can find their podcast at gimletmedia.com/heavyweight. Or you can just Google or just get it wherever you get your podcasts.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦是《重量级》的主持人。他这个故事的制片人是斯蒂维·莱恩。《重量级》刚开始他们的第三季，第一集是关于喜剧演员罗布·科德里的。你可以在 gimletmedia.com/heavyweight 找到他们的播客。或者你可以直接谷歌搜索，或在你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu. People who put together today's show include Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Neil Drumming, Damian Grave, David Kestenbaum, Anna Martin, Miki Meek, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们今天的节目由黛安·吴制作。参与制作今天节目的人员包括佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·齐维斯、尼尔·德拉明、达米安·格雷夫、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、安娜·马丁、米基·米克、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德。我们的总编辑是苏珊·伯顿。
Special thanks today to Victoria Camp, Seung Min Kim, Meagan Shepard, Ben Terris, Kalila Holt, Peter Bresnan, Jorge Just, Alex Blumberg, Maurice Chammah, Amanda Marzullo, Elie Mystal, Lawrence Stengel, Richard Holwell, Pamela Bresnahan, and Nina Totenberg.
今天特别感谢维多利亚·坎普、金世敏、梅根·谢泼德、本·泰里斯、卡丽拉·霍尔特、彼得·布雷斯南、豪尔赫·贾斯特、亚历克斯·布隆伯格、莫里斯·查马、阿曼达·马祖洛、埃利·米斯特尔、劳伦斯·斯滕格尔、理查德·霍尔韦尔、帕梅拉·布雷斯纳汉和妮娜·托滕伯格。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, The Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org，你可以在那里免费收听我们超过600集的档案。《美国生活》由 PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给各公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Every time he and I play tennis, he makes me so mad the way he serves. And when I get mad, he always reminds me--
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。每次我和他打网球，他发球的方式总是让我很生气。当我生气时，他总是提醒我——
Quiet discussion, and decency, and courtesy. That's the way our court works.
安静的讨论、体面和礼貌。这就是我们法院的工作方式。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。